说话人 1: 哈喽，兄弟们，欢迎来到真实社交，我是Jackson，今天给大家带来一期聊天讲解，是一个比较远古的聊天记录了呀，但是聊的非常的好，反应非常的不错
说话人 1: 有很多的一个技术点给大家
说话人 1: 啊展示一下
说话人 1: 首先我给大家描述一下认识这个女生的一个背景情况
说话人 1: 当时我是在等红绿灯，准备过马路，在一个商圈里面，我就看到这个女生，她可能有点急，她闯着红灯，飞奔过来，往上面走，我看到她闯红灯，我就觉得这个女的很叛逆，很酷，所以我就要
说话人 1: 去认识一下她，我就直接上去把她给叫停，跟她简单沟通了一下，甚至于都没有有效沟通，甚至于只是过了一个社交上勾点，再把她的微信给收了
说话人 1: 所以说吸引并不是很强，我们要在聊天上面做一个很强的一个吸引，才能把她给邀约出来
说话人 1: 大家看我是怎么做的，也是通过了验证，马上就是一个
说话人 1: 同理心给他砸过去，都没好好聊聊就跑了，我是杰森
说话人 1: 兄弟们，这句话首先它是一个同理心陈述，给妹子一个我是正常人的感觉，我们都没好好聊聊，你就跑了，给他一个我是正常人的感觉
说话人 1: 还有第二个我的目的，这是在为我后面的一个邀约做铺垫
说话人 1: 铺垫这个东西非常重要，在你做邀约，做升级，
说话人 1: 做游戏规则的时候，都要去做铺垫这个东西，这个非常的重要
说话人 1: 他给我回了，你好，我叫什么什么，他把他的名字发过来
说话人 1:  OK 是比较有礼貌，或者说是比较有窗口的，至少他们的不是一个很负向的回复，是一个很正常的一个回复，已经合格了，我要的效果已经达到了
说话人 1: 我说，你说你在这里上班，我感觉你是做医美的
说话人 1: 因为商场它很多整容脸，做医美的，而且他又跑的很快，我就感觉他是做医美的
说话人 1: 我就把我的感觉给他陈述出来，这个就代表了你自己的一个看法，大概能让别人了解你是什么样的一个人，大概的了解一下，不是很了解
说话人 1: 他说不是的，OK，马上我就开始筛选他，我说，那就好，不会给我推销什么东
说话人 1: 东西，就我这句话是在做一个推拉，我说我也不是销售，我就路过，我说我也不是销售，是正常来撩你的，就是一个路人甲，比较帅气的路人甲
说话人 1: OK，这是给了一个幽默的一个表达，女生马上就会有反应，就一连串的一段话，就可以把她给逗笑，把她的情绪给拉出来
说话人 1: 很多兄弟不知道怎么聊天，不知道怎么拉情绪，就用推拉就行
说话人 1: 就用你的幽默就行了，但是要结合实际情况，不能乱用所谓的笑话，还有你所谓的幽默，不能乱用，不能用的很刻意，你知道吗
说话人 1: 必须得该用的时候才把它用出来
说话人 1: OK，然后这里他说哈哈哈，比较帅气的路人甲，这里已经出现一点窗口了，咱们马上要做什么
说话人 1: 邀约出来聊，看一下他的
说话人 1: 购买度大不大
说话人 1: 你知道我一般第一个邀约，我是不会报很大的一个成功率的
说话人 1: 我第一个邀约就是试探他的一个窗口到底到了什么程度，我才会去做其他的一些操作
说话人 1: 我说这周有时间吗
说话人 1: 咱们可以约一个快速的咖啡，可以出来坐一坐
说话人 1: 这句话的意思是，约一个快速的咖啡，就代表我不会跟你见很久，
说话人 1: 这场咖啡很轻松，没有那些所谓的看电影、吃饭、游乐场、去哪玩，没有那些玩意，很轻松、很 easy 的一个氛围，就让他更容易能出来见咱们
说话人 1: 这里发的是一句英文，他这里识别错了，也有可能是我口音不好，我说的是跳过废话， skip the bullshit
说话人 1: 这句话的意思是不是学谁的话术
说话人 1: 它代表了一个意思
说话人 1: 就是你的合理性，就是跳过废话，就代表了你的合理性，就是你不想废话，去约咖啡，去邀约，他是为了邀约这句话而存在的，不要乱用，说谁的话术
说话人 1: 到了这里，第二天她才回我，不好意思，太困了，回家就睡着了
说话人 1: OK，有两种情况，一是她看到了，她不知道怎么回
说话人 1: 他不知道怎么回的原因的底层逻辑是，他怕得罪你
说话人 1: 他如果说不出来，他就怕得罪你
说话人 1: 他如果说出来，他就会很随便
说话人 1: 所以说他在这样的一个心理情况，这是第一种可能性
说话人 1: 第二种可能性就是他他们的真的太困了，回家就睡着了，没看到我的消息
说话人 1: 但是咱们无所谓，那件事已经翻篇了，他不愿意接这个邀约，咱们就继续聊，聊到他们的他愿意出来为止
说话人 1: 这里我说，看着你的时候还蛮精神的，应该前一天晚上有失眠吧
说话人 1: 因为我经常也这样，只要白天睡多了，晚上他就会失眠，会导致第二天的一个状态
说话人 1: 所以说我在这里把我的感受，把我的经历给他陈述出来，来冷读
说话人 1: 他的一个经历，他的一个状态，这种比你直接问你昨天晚上失眠了吗要好很多，因为你这种问法是不会带有需求感的，这个很重要，兄弟们
说话人 1: 这里他说上班累
说话人 1: OK，他上一句已经说他上班累了，意思是还不能出来见，因为他很累，不想见任何人
说话人 1: 咱们要读懂这个东西，你不能回他，你说，累，休息一会就好了，休息一会就可以出来见了，没事，出来见很轻松的，你不能这样去干住他，咱们就直接放掉就行了
说话人 1: 你直接放掉会代表你很没有需求感，是一个很灵活的一个男人，而不是
说话人 1: 是那种很歇斯底里，很他们的舔狗的那种男人，很缺女人的那种男人
说话人 1: 所以说咱们这里回了，等你身体好了，咱们再约，很轻松的一句话，给女人感觉很舒服，就她会想，这个人还是至少挺，这个人至少挺合得来的，会给她一种这样的感觉，至少是个正常人
说话人 1: 然后她说好，这段时间一直上班太累了，然后这段话就已经结束了，我就等她休息好，我再去
说话人 1: 约她
说话人 1: OK，然后过了大概 8 天的一个时间，我也是我经常用的一个打招呼的办法，就是直接拍一拍，不用去发他们的什么文字啊，什么今天想你了，什么你在哪里，就不用发那些，直接拍一拍，最省事
说话人 1: 她给我发了一个表情，因为她不知道回什么消息，她就给我发了一个表情
说话人 1: 这里我回了一个感觉上班上蒙了的样子，这里我们还是在给一个价值，给一个情
说话人 1: 情绪价值也算是一个冷读吧，比你直接问他在干嘛要好很多，哪怕这个东西他很不切实际
说话人 1: 如果你说的很不切实际，他会回答你，他会纠正你的说法，实不实际
说话人 1: 但是我们一定要这样去做，然后他说好嘞，他他们的整天在给我负能量，然后我没理他这个东西，我直接就以这个点展开，就由这个点展开，直接把邀约给他做出来
说话人 1: 我说那不如抽个空跟Jack
说话人 1: 出来聊聊天，找点power
说话人 1: 你看兄弟们，是由女生她的话语，转换成邀约，非常的丝滑，非常的自然
说话人 1: 你们要有这种思维逻辑，去找任何字眼，能把它提升成为你想要的一个东西，去把它延伸一下
说话人 1: 然后这里他说哈哈哈，你不也没跟我聊吗
说话人 1: 兄弟们注意一下，这个东西它是一个废物测试，你不也没跟我聊吗
说话人 1: 就他在让你去投资他，让你去找他聊
说话人 1: OK，咱们不理他这个东西，我直接给出我的需求，还是往邀约那方面靠
说话人 1: 我也可以用另外一个，我觉得我们两个要心灵相通才能聊得起劲，我也可以给这样的一个话术，但是这次我是去偏向于邀约的一个方面，把这个废策给破解，同时又把邀约给他强化一下，我说我觉得当面比较有诚意，哈哈，然后下周哪天可以呀
说话人 1: OK，这里他的最担心的问题终于出现了，就他真实害怕，真实顾忌的一个东西终于出现了，他说我社恐，然后
说话人 1: 很多兄弟可能到了这个时候，他说，哎，不用社恐啊，没啥啊，就大不了见一，见一下，又不用怎么样，就框架一下就软了，就意图一下就软了
说话人 1: 很多时候从这个时候就开始聊，很多兄弟们，所以说这一点要注意一下，女生社恐是有原因的，不是因为她真的社，她真的怕见任何人
说话人 1: 我说我的攻击性会看人，也会有很温柔的一面呀
说话人 1: 这句话是什么意思
说话人 1: 意思就是不是那种大老虎，就看到女的就扑上去，一顿舔，一顿吃
说话人 1: 我是要看人的，你必须是我很感兴趣，我觉得很可以的，我才会有其他的一面
说话人 1: 他说我怕看到你不敢说话
说话人 1: OK，这句话的意思是他怕那个空气冷场，他怕场面整个冷下来，你给不了话题
说话人 1: 他又不是那种很主动的人，他又不是那种很外向的人
说话人 1: 这里可以分辨出他大概是长期属
说话人 1: 属性比较重一点，大概具体还得出来聊了才知道，这只是前面的一个预判
说话人 1: 这里我就直接解决他的一个顾虑，我说有我在，空气不会凝固的，就把他的这个社恐的问
说话人 1: OK，咱们下面还来了一个推拉，马上又把他的情绪给拉出来，我说你得像个男人一样，别婆婆妈妈的
说话人 1: 兄弟们看到没有
说话人 1: 这样就把女生的污
说话人 1: 位置给他压低了，因为他在婆婆妈妈的，让他他们的像个男人一样，别那么装逼
说话人 1: OK，这里情绪已经出来了，马上就开始答应邀约了，他说下周我得看看哦
说话人 1: 兄弟们，这个信号已经很好了，这个已经不是很敷衍的那种了，是很好的一个进度了，咱们只需要把他后面给他具体落定一下，给他确定一下就 OK 了
说话人 1: 然后这里我做了一个有确信感的东西
说话人 1: 说，别像其他女生一样嘴炮哈，同时又给了他一个我身边女生很多的感觉，也是一个高价值的一个暗示
说话人 1: 然后他说，哇，看样子约了不少女生，海王嘛
说话人 1: 这个时候废策就来了，很多兄弟以为可能她在夸你，你就跳起来了，千万不要，这里她是在给你一个废物测试，你不能跟上
说话人 1: 我说退役了，就是我现在不是海王了，马上我就说江渝女生爱放水，我就说重庆这边的女生就喜欢水别人，意思是让她他们的别水我
说话人 1: 她说是不是哦，说我不是重庆的，我说是不是见了才知道
说话人 1: 意思是你水不水，你爱不爱放水，我们见了就知道你水不水了，还是往邀约那方面推
说话人 1: 往邀约那方面做一个输出，一定要往那边靠，你的话语，你的整个逻辑必须要往邀约那方面靠，这样女生才
说话人 1: 还能出的来
说话人 1: 她不可能主动约你去看电影、约你去吃饭、约你去喝咖啡，你别等着她来邀约你
说话人 1: 我回了一句像浙江的，因为她给我感觉她是像那种做主播的，杭州那边非常多做主播的，我就把她联想到她是浙江的
说话人 1: 她说不是的，她问我，你是重庆的吗
说话人 1: OK，兄弟们记住，女生只要再问你是哪里的，你这个人
说话人 1: 本身的一些问题，关于你这个人的问题，他就一定是对你感兴趣的
说话人 1: 所以到了这里，吸引是绝对有了，你们只需要把这条路走稳，这个女生就一定会出来，知道吧
说话人 1: 千万不能下头
说话人 1: 问她那里到底是哪里的，希望不是山西
说话人 1: 兄弟们，这里再问她哪里的，又给了一个价值，而不是索取她的信息价值
说话人 1: 什么是价值
说话人 1: 就是我说希
说话人 1: 希望不是山西，这里我埋了一个种子，我铺垫了一下，因为我后面要说山西的女人怎么怎么样
说话人 1: 她如果懂了这个梗，大多数女人都能懂这个梗，因为基本上全国的女人都知道山西的女人彩礼很贵
说话人 1: 你们可以看到我是为这个东西埋了很多的一个种子
说话人 1: 她说你再猜猜看我是哪里的，这个女的很喜欢卖关子，她也玩起来了
说话人 1: 知道吧
说话人 1: 女人她在跟你玩起来了，你就知道你们已经进入一种很暧昧的一个氛围了，非常好的一个感觉
说话人 1: 然后她说猜中了，OK，到了这里，我马上就进入一个男女框架
说话人 1: 这个女的，她是必定会踩进我这个陷阱，踩进我男女框架这个陷阱
说话人 1: 我说，那我不能娶你了，已经成功进入一个男女框架了，而且是她还不能拒绝的男女框架，非常的自然，是她自己跳进来的，不是强行塞给她的，感觉是不一样的，兄弟们
说话人 1: OK，这里我在试探短期属性，她适不适合
说话人 1: 她适不适合他们的
说话人 1: 她适不适合做情人
说话人 1: 在做这样的一个试探
说话人 1: 很丝滑，很圆滑的一个操作
说话人 1: 我说，因为你是山西的，所以我
说话人 1: 不能娶你，因为彩礼很高，咱们只能他们的做情人
说话人 1: 女生的哈哈哈，猜中了一个字，她说什么鬼，咱们只能做情人
说话人 1: 这里可以看到女生并不是很排斥这个东西，她没有一下很生气，没有很什么，这已经就好了，我们已经给她种下一个概念了，我们是有短期属性，所以后面只要往这方面发展就 OK 了
说话人 1: 我说你发句语音，我听口音猜，如果说她只有一个西，确实猜不出是哪里，因为全国带西字的太多了，我只有靠她的口音来猜
说话人 1: 她这里给我说，我说语音你就能听出我是哪的吗
说话人 1: OK，这里我们还是要做一些价值，肯定要给一些价值，你不能直接猜，诶，山西、陕西、广西，你不能直接回答
说话人 1: 这里我给了一个信息价值，我说首先肯定不是北方的，代表我很有逻
说话人 1: 然后我说江西，因为当时我也是猜的，因为那个口音我也听不出来，脑子里冒出江西这个，我就把它直接给抛出来
说话人 1: 他说他的确不是北方的，他说你再猜一下，我说湘西，他说为什么不是广西
说话人 1: 这里他不想再瞒了，因为已经猜了两三次了，他就把自己的地方说出来了
说话人 1: 我说他们的，广西的口音我听得出的，你隐藏口音了，兄弟们审
说话人 1: 什么时候才能真正的有熟悉感
说话人 1: 才能真正的代表你这个人真实
说话人 1: 是你开始乱骂的时候
说话人 1: 所谓的乱骂的时候，就是他们的
说话人 1: 你如果不敢跟女生他们的，那这个女生你就得不到，OK
说话人 1: 你自己问你自己，你平时在生活中，在跟你朋友说话的时候，你是在女生面前那种很乖、很保守、很有责任心、很礼貌、很绅士的人吗
说话人 1: 你不是，你是一个很低俗，很好色，满嘴脏话的人，你是一个这样的人，所以说你不需要他们的隐藏你原本的样子，这样的女人永远永远你得不到，你如果不在她面前展示你真实的一面
说话人 1: 他说我没有隐藏口音，其实广西的话我是能听出来的，因为广西表妹嘛
说话人 1: 他说就广西广西人说的话，他会有一部分会有口音
说话人 1: 他这里开始解释了，代表他还是很在乎咱们的一个看法
说话人 1: 因为我说他们的，就表面上从字面意思上看起来是比较生气的，没有很生气，一点点就打情骂俏那种
说话人 1: 他在那里解释是迎合我们的一个状态，所以说在这里可以看到框架
说话人 1: 是咱们这边高，非常好的一个flow
说话人 1: 我说只去过北海，体验还可以，广西我没有去过其他地方
说话人 1: 只说我知道的一个东西，让我给他一个我的看法
说话人 1: 他说北海我读小学的时候就去过一次
说话人 1: 我从这句话我察觉出他是一个比较宅的，我说你是那种比较宅的，他说他读小学的时候就去过一次，我会大概猜到他可能就喜欢宅在家里，或者说就那几个朋友一起玩，没有很强的一个阅历，没有
说话人 1: 我那种很爱冒险的一个性格
说话人 1: 她说我老家的街我都不认识路，平时小姐妹喊的话就会出去
说话人 1: 这里咱们就知道这个女的她是真的非常的宅，因为我前面的一个冷读大概是到位了，她会有一种感觉，这个男人可能还比较懂她，可能是见识的女生多了，或者说是比较懂她，反正怎么样都好，她觉
说话人 1: 就会有这样一个感受，因为我们猜的很准
说话人 1: 这里我又进入一个两性话题，得好好调教一下
说话人 1: 调教它是一个很安全的一个词，因为我说的调教是带有两性框架，是带有性话题，但是他具体说的东西又是调教他宅的那一面，知道吧
说话人 1: 词用在这种情况下，它就非常的安全，它不会让女人反感
说话人 1: 你如果用在
说话人 1: 那种本身性话题就已经比较浓烈了，你再去用这个，那会比较难以收场，如果说这个女生她有抵触的话，所以你们也要注意这个问题，就聊骚这个东西，你不能骚过头了
说话人 1: 然后这里她回了两个捂脸的表情，就稍微有一点害羞的样子
说话人 1: OK，她这里已经察觉到了我的一个短期属性，她说看得出来你喜欢出去玩
说话人 1: 这里咱们要先收一下，因为我不知道她的一个属性到底是能不能接受这样的一个尺度，所以这里我先收一下
说话人 1: 我说但你知道我不抽烟、不喝酒、也不赌博
说话人 1: 不是学谁啊，我是真的不抽烟、不喝酒、也不喜欢打麻将、也不喜欢打牌
说话人 1: 有一些他们的常用语，非有一些他要说学谁学谁，那也没办法
说话人 1: 她说我不知道，哈哈哈，你喜欢钓鱼
说话人 1: 这个女生，她非常的逗啊，她说我是海王，又喜欢钓鱼，她说她自己是鱼，相当于，很明显的一个废策，但是很好玩的一个废策
说话人 1: 这里我先拉回来，我说复杂的小朋友，怪不得你累
说话人 1: 因为她前面说她很累嘛，我说怪不得你累，因为想的太几把多了，都还没出来，扯那么多干嘛
说话人 1: 这里他发了一个表情，回了一句话，他说女人的第六感
说话人 1: OK，他这里也在开始幽默了，开始逗你开心了，因为我觉得这个点确实很好笑，他说你在钓鱼，我确实感觉到这个女人她已经打开了
说话人 1: 他发了两个笑哭，他说但是嘛，猜疑多了不会觉得很烦吗
说话人 1: 我说所以我喜欢真诚，也待人真诚
说话人 1: OK，这里已经把咱们的一个舒适感要传达给她，我喜欢真诚的
说话人 1: 也待人真诚，我们的一致性要做起来，不能做那种很假
说话人 1: 只知道他们的，只知道的那种屌丝
说话人 1: 他说是吗
说话人 1: 发了我依旧待人真诚，但不再寄于厚望
说话人 1: 女人一旦跟你说这种话了，代表她已经真的在跟你谈心了，已经很真实的暴露在你面前了，是很好的，非常好的信号
说话人 1: 出来，你真的只要不犯错，可以，可以促成你的长期关系，或者说再去收尾
说话人 1: 但我们
说话人 1: 要分清楚它的属性
说话人 1: 这里我说看来是被渣过，因为从他这句话可以读出来，他以前肯定是被渣过，或者说被伤害过
说话人 1: 这里他说，哈哈，我先洗漱去了
说话人 1: 隔了一阵子，他给我发了个表情，还想在微信上面聊，但是我不想再聊了，因为在微信上面聊的太费劲了
说话人 1: 我就给他发了一句邀约，我说现在还在工作，要不咱们下周出来聊
说话人 1: 下周你给我说放假的时候，他说好的
说话人 1: 到了下周的时候，我发现他没有跟我打招呼，或者说跟我邀约，我就去做了一个试探的一个动作，也是拍一拍，这里他又回了一个表情
说话人 1: OK，这里咱们直接延续上面的一个邀约操作，一点不扯废话，一点不扯淡
说话人 1: Skip the bullshit，然后她说还在加班，这里我就在调侃她，我们现在已经很熟了，真的就可以开玩笑了，就可以开那些很，很好玩的一些玩笑了，一定要有这种熟悉感，妹子跟你见她才会放松，她放松你才有机会，她没有防御，你才能打出真实伤害，知道吗
说话人 1: 兄弟们
说话人 1: 我说你是厂妹吗
说话人 1: 怎么一直在加班
说话人 1: 我说很好奇你是啥工作，这里完全在调侃她
说话人 1: 她说我不是，你猜猜
说话人 1: 然后我这里在
说话人 1: 我笑她，我说你总让我猜，我感觉脑子都不够用了，你就直接告诉我就行了
说话人 1: 你在观音桥上班吗
说话人 1: 那柜姐嘛，就是
说话人 1: 因为我对那边商场上班的女生，我大概就会猜一个柜姐或者医美
说话人 1: 她说你不猜怎么知道
说话人 1: 你猜一下
说话人 1: 她说哪里是柜姐啊
说话人 1: 柜姐应该不用加班吧
说话人 1: 我瞎猜了一个，我说边上有小孩游乐场那种
说话人 1: 她说不是，我刚刚下班，然后回来了
说话人 1: OK，这里我还是先问一下邀约，看她有什么说法，看她有什么
说话人 1: 窗口，他说这个我还没开始排呢，就要先跟他们排一下才知道
说话人 1: OK，这里我知道他真的是还在排假，我说那我今天的目的就是来提醒你一下，不要他们的把我给忘了，就很严肃很认真的跟他说这个东西，而不是跟他开玩笑
说话人 1: 他说你是什么时候休息吗
说话人 1: 我说我周内都OK
说话人 1: 他说，平时都要上班，是吗
说话人 1: 都是在做一个调度，兄弟们，这些都没有什么技巧了，这些都是在做一个调度
说话人 1: 我说还好，我上班比较自由，但周末的话会比较忙
说话人 1: 兄弟们看到没有
说话人 1: 这是女生她在跟随我们的一个调度，就跟着我们的一个时间表走，是非常迎合，非常讨好的一个状态，知道吧
说话人 1: 这就是有吸引之后，你有标准之后，你有框架之后，才能得到的一个东西，女人好的反应才会得得到
说话人 1: 他说好的吧，我要看一下
说话人 1: 什么时候开始休
说话人 1: 到了约会的前一天，她给我发了一个明天休息
说话人 1: 就女人她是在主动的邀约你，这种已经相当于女人在主动的邀约你了，这就算女人的邀约，她会说她具体某个点，而且还提前给你说
说话人 1: 我说周末有点忙，我们约早点
说话人 1: 后面就是一个调度的情况了
说话人 1: 到了这里，她突然来一句，方便我朋友跟我一起吗
说话人 1: 发了一个表情，不行的意思，就是不行的意思
说话人 1: 他说，那没事，我喊他等我吧
说话人 1: 兄弟们，你们要有最基本的情商，你看女人她天生的情商就很高，我发了一个撇嘴的表情，她就知道我不愿意，这个事情不能答应，她就退回去了
说话人 1: 当然这是有吸引的前提
说话人 1: 女人给你发一个表情，你还要问她为什么发这个表情
说话人 1: 你为什么，哎，这个表情好难看，哎，这个表情让我很不舒
说话人 1: 舒服，还要给他说这个东西，你说你怎么能撩到妹，对吧
说话人 1: 你要有最基本的情商，你要能读出最基本的一个潜沟通
说话人 1: 这里我还调侃了他一下，我说你朋友正吗
说话人 1: 要看他的一个窗，我这里还在推拉他一把，他打了个省略号，这里马上我又拉了一下，我说我是说我可以给他安排一个，还是在做一个调侃，还是在做一个幽默，自娱自乐的一个事情
说话人 1: 她说，嗯，她下午没那么快出来
说话人 1: OK，这里我就知道她是一个人出来了
说话人 1: 她说那在观音桥哪里
说话人 1: 我说星巴克吧
说话人 1: 后面也是一个调度的一个聊天记录
说话人 1: OK，到了当天是带她过去约会了，这就是一个完整的一个聊天记录，也是把女生的框架压在咱们的下面，感觉到有很强的一个吸引呢，处理一些她出来的一些焦虑
说话人 1: 去一些担心，处理了之后，再做一些推拉，做一些框架性的一个东西，就可以直接见面了
说话人 1: 其实非常的简单啊，兄弟们，只要你们见够了足够多的女人，很多时候你不要再疯狂的去脑子里面模拟技巧，去想技巧
说话人 1: 很多时候这个视频只是让你有确信感，你去多认识正妹，你自然会达到一个这样的状态
说话人 1: 所以最重要的是你们自己的一个
说话人 1: 经历，而不是什么话术，还有什么惯例，或者说什么套路，是靠你自己的经历，还有你自己的心态，你的框架，这几方面的东西才能足够支撑你把妹子给约出来，并且成功跟她发生关系
说话人 1: OK，这里是真实社交，兄弟们下期再见